- (Kelly) I love your dress.
- (Phoebe) Really?
- (Kelly) And with these shoes.
- (Phoebe) I was scared about these shoes,
it is the first time I've worn them,
which is like right now.
- (Kelly) I have to be paid
a pretty good amount of money
to wear heels like that.
- (Phoebe) I mean those are so cute.
- (Kelly) And they're
still easy to walk in.
(Everyone laughing)
Have you met the ladies?
- (Phoebe) No. I am so excited.
- (Kate) Awesome.
- (Jane) So nice to meet you.
- (Kelly) So many funny ladies today?
- (Phoebe) This is great.
- (Kelly) I know I was very
excited about this panel.
So you moderated a panel
with Michelle Obama
and brought your parents. I love this.
Were they impressed?
- (Phoebe) So, Michelle?
I moderated for Michelle Obama
for her 'BECOMING' book tour,
which is insane.
- (Kelly) Yeah, absolutely.
- (Phoebe) Insane.
- And the last show
was on mother's day in Nashville.
So Michelle was like,
oh, you should bring,
your parents it would be like so fun.
So I was like oh, okay, cool.
And my parents are truly,
they're from the Midwest
they are so over everything.
So I was like,
Michelle invited you to
come to the last show.
And my mom goes, I don't know.
I think I might be tired then.
(Everyone laughing)
- (Phoebe) Really? Really
Octavia You're too tired?
(Laughing)
And so she was like, let me get back to
- (Kelly) She planned being tired?
- (Phoebe) Yeah, like
the month in advance.
She was like, let me get
back to you. You know
And I was like okay, I'm not
a telemarketer, but okay.
- (Kelly) Yeah, and then
you're like Michelle
- (Pheobe) Yes.
- (Kelly) freaking Obama.
- (Phoebe) Yes But they got on the plane.
They had a great time,
but they were like out first
flight out the next morning,
they were like, get us back to our house.
- (Kelly) I kind of love
that your family like that,
that was not impressed by stuff like that.
You know what I'm saying?
They keep you grounded.
- (Phoebe) Yeah, they do
- (Jane) Can I tell you my
Michelle Obama story real quick?
- (Phoebe) Yes.
- (Jane) I introduced
her, I'm from Chicago
and I introduced her at an
event during the 2012 time.
My whole family came
and we were walking with in and aunt Marge
91 years old about this
tall. We're all tall people.
She's about this tall, she's
much closer to the ground.
She ran so fast at Michelle Obama,
that secret service was like,
(audience laughing)
- (Phoebe) Oh my god!
- (Jane) Yeah, stop that
little red head old lady.
- (Kelly) She's Crazy.
- (Jane) And Michelle Obama
wrapped her up in her arms
and it was the sweetest thing.
- (Kelly) Awwwww.That's nice.
- (Jane) Lovely. Yeah.
Michelle Obama is great.
- (Kelly) I love hearing stuff like that.
- (Phoebe) Yeah she's fanatstic.
- (Kelly) Like behind the scenes,
you always hear horrible
things about people.
You never hear the good stuff.
That's so lovely.
- (Jane) She's lovely.
- (Phoebe) Yeah, The real deal.
- (Kelly) Yeah. Well, Kate,
have you ever invited your
family to events that maybe
didn't pan out?
- (Kate)The only thing that
We'll compare it to this is when
the very first time I
introduced my father to
Jane Lynch, he says,
he goes big deal.
(everyone laughing)
- (Kate) But that's his sense of humor.
That means drink. That means drink.
And she got it.
_ (Jane) Big deal.
(laughing)
- (Kate) she loves it.
- (Jane) Why should I meet her?
She never bought me a drink.
- (Kate) That's what he said.
- (Kelly) Oh my God, I love
- (Jane) I was waiting for
- (Kelly) Oh my God, She prepped you.
- (Jane) I think so.
I Knew what was going to
happen and I loved it.
- (Kelly) I've to prep my friends
not to ask my mom for the truth.
(Everyone laughing)
She'll tell you, she ain't
holding back. Not a liar.
So Phoebe and your new book.
I love your title by
the way. It's amazing.
But you talk about running
your own production company,
which is an amazing thing
to do. Congratulations.
- (Phoebe) Thanks.
- (Kelly) I mean,
and how would you rate
yourself as a boss though?
- (Phoebe) You know, I think
I would give myself a 8 out of 10,
but I like to get that I'm a boss,
so I always want to invite
my employees out for like,
let's hang out on Friday or Saturday.
And they're always like, what?
(audience laughing)
I don't want to hang out.
I see you five days a week.
I don't want to hang out with you. Yeah.
So I'm like, okay, I'm just
going to go home alone. Got it.
- (Kelly) It's like, you're like,
it's like that you have
the dad or the mom,
like forced family fun.
- (Phoebe) Ess.
I'm a big proponent of that.
And they're just like, stop it.
We don't need to go bowling. We're good.
- (Kelly) I love bowling.
- (Phoebe) Me too.
- (Kelly) I'll go bowling with you.
I'm not good at it, but I like it.
But yeah, there's a difference.
And So your specials called,
sorry, Harriet Tubman.
So what does that title mean?
You're great with titles.
- (Phoebe) Thank you.
I, my specials is a lot of fun.
It's very ignorant. You know,
like I joke about my sex
life and my boyfriend.
So I'm just like, sorry, Harriet,
that you had to like learn
about like GPS naturally for me
to be alive to do this.
(Laughing)
- (Jane) Was it worth it Harriet?
- (Phoebe) I don't know.
- (Kelly) oh my god. It's so great.
Well, wait, everybody,
you got to see this cover.
I want you on a zoom
and it's such an amazing cover as well.
Phoebe's book is called,
Please don't sit on my bed
in you're outside clothes.
Be sure to check it out.
I love that dress too.
- (Phoebe) Thank you.
- (Kelly) I want that dress.
- (Phoebe) It was Valentino.
- (Kelly) Ooh
- (Phoebe) my stylist got it.
- (Kelly) Okay.
- (Phoebe) Yeah, so.
- (Kelly) Oh my God.
Anytime I look good is my stylist, not Me.
- (Phoebe) Exactly. So
I was just like, okay,
I'm going to be very precious with this.
And then as soon as we, I was like,
take the pictures really
fast. And I was like,
let me take it off and
put on, you know, my Zara.
Cause I felt more comfortable.
- (Kelly) You know what?
Keep the tag on, send it back.
- (Phoebe) Ess.